hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast problems when breeding
laboratory mice why our pups dying this
is presented by dr. Ellen Weber we're
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots for
more information please visit lab roots
com my name is soon family roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this is the event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
note that your viewing this presentation
in the slide window to enlarge the
window just click on the screen icon
located on the lower right finally if
you have trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce our speaker dr. Ellen Weber Dr
Weber is a postdoctoral research fellow
at Stanford University she has a
master's of science and biology and
received her PhD in ethology at the
Department of Animal environment and
health Swedish University Agricultural
Sciences in 2015 dr. Weber's research
focuses on welfare of laboratory animals
and she has worked with laboratory
rodents for more than 10 years with a
main focus on maternal behavior and
reproduction in mice please join me in
welcoming dr. Webber and I will now turn
the presentation over to her
thank you very much for that
introduction and I would also like to
start by thanking the organizers for
inviting me to give this talk and this
is a topic that I really think it's
important and I have been working with
this subject of public health if you
lost yes so I will start this talk by
giving just a short background on the
problem of the pub mortality and then I
will go through some of the experimental
studies that I have been doing and
finally concluding the results in these
studies and give him some practical
recommendations when breeding of or
cream ice problems with pups dying are
frequent frequently encountered and most
people that work with mouse breeding are
very well aware of this problem and the
situation is for those little times that
you have a pregnant female and they
enter the animal room and you can see
that she has given birth to liquor but
then later during the day or maybe the
day first days after birth and you will
enter the animal room again and you will
find that there are no props in the cage
or you will find that the liquor has
decreased so there are fewer pups and
you can also find parts of top scattered
in the cage so a breeding record can
basically look like the one you can see
here you have the different liquors like
the first part i will show you here you
have the cage one we have a female that
gave birth to in total six liquors the
first later died the second litter was
successfully wing then the third little
diet again the fourth litter was
successfully weaned and so on and you
have another female will give birth
successfully weaned the first deserve
then a second later died and then she
had four more letters and a third
example of a female who gave birth to
two liters that actually died both 11
but then she successfully weaned a third
sometimes only one or two facts are lost
but it can also be the phenomenon that
actually the whole entire litter is lost
since breeding is a very important part
of providing animals research when pups
are dying and especially when entire
liquors are dying this of course
companies planning a research and this
it's also initial and welfare because
they have a lot of animals dying on a
regular basis but you don't really know
why the perhaps are dying so if you
don't know why they died but they still
are dying on a regular basis that's
that's a problem this problem of course
varies between different facilities some
experience a lot of problems some don't
experience any problems at all just to
give an example and this is data from a
breeding facility and we looked at like
six and weld seam lines to very commonly
used mines they had thirty two percent
of entire liters for twenty percent
football see that's quite a huge amount
of entirely just being lost so some some
warm background loss of liquors or pups
and breeding colonies is usually
attributed to stress I think this is
very interesting because stress is not
one event it's not one thing so arguing
that my mouse pups are lost due to
stress is almost like saying they can
die from anything because as I just said
there are many different things that can
be stressful for mice so the thing is to
try to rule out what can't wrestle and
be everything that course in locality
few studies have actually addressed
these problems you can read about very
about little mortality or calf mortality
but there are few research studies
actually investigating the underlying
causes for this problem in under normal
cleaning facilities
under normal conditions and it's also as
I said before it's just not just little
loss it's also also single parts so one
solution to this problem just from if
you look at it from a point of view of
planning and trying to provide research
animals is to just keep more breathing
angles and several breeding facilities
actually do this they maintain more
reading animals to compensate for the
pat mcafee but this of course will
increase the workload it will also
increase the cost and it also
counteracts the three our goal of
reducing the number of animals fields
for research so and there are several
problems with this packaging and also
you don't really know why they don't you
just try to cope with the problem and
when when keeping additional breeding
animals you might also end up with a lot
of extra animals that will not be so
then you have to euthanize a lot of
circus animals so this was just a very
short background but the question I
really want to address when this talk is
why the cops are guy i have discussed
puffs mortality with a lot of people
that are involved in breathing in many
different ways and it's very interesting
because when discussing this problem
there are so many different assumptions
on why the cops are dying so first of
all it's very common that to assume that
first letters die and that that's normal
for mice to actually lose their entire
liquors and because of mother is
inexperienced or for other reasons
secondly and it's a very common belief
that females kills the boxspring and
this is not very strange that people
think this because if you come into an
animal room and you find pups that are
part eaten you will of course assume
that mother has killed them and but when
i try to discuss this and how
know that they have actually infield
what what comes up is actually more the
situation that all perhaps are found
eaten and it's very difficult to know if
the female actually did kill the
offspring or if you just ate parts that
are already did so but to avoid the
killing and there's a widespread
practice of actually leaving the female
undisturbed out the population to avoid
that the female will kill them to clean
so what I wonder if is all these
assumptions true or it's adjustments so
let's start with the first assumption
that it's more common the first litter
start to find out if this was true we
use data from a breeding facility and
we're entire letters were lost so in
total we used 111 parental couples from
black 6 and 61 in front of couples from
LC what we did find was that it was much
more common for like six mice to use the
first letters compared to valve sees and
it's also sometimes commonly or
sometimes assume that if a female
wouldn't do this her first liver then
she will also lose her subsequent
theaters so some have the practice of
removing for the female from the reading
if she lose the first liquor but we
could not find a relationship between
losing the first liquor and losing
subsequent livers
and if you want to know more about this
study more detail there is a publication
on this so to the next assumption then
and do female mice kill their pups and
when you think about this you can
actually also wonder does it really
matter how the pups die well for my
point of view I think this is very
important because if you assume why the
pups die and you don't really know why
they died and it would be very difficult
to prevent the problem so it's actually
I think it's very important to actually
try to find out how the top style and
what causes the mortality because that's
the only way to try to learn more and to
to know how to prevent it but still I
want to go through two very commonly
used terms infanticide and cannibalism
as i said i have talked a lot of people
beating mice and i come in contact with
people that use these terms on a regular
basis they say that they have problems
with an infant side or female or that
they lose a lot of pups due to
cannibalism so if you look at the
terminology and what it means so
infanticide is clearly on so compared to
cannibalism that could actually just
include eating dead offspring without
killing them so it depends on sometimes
you divide this into active or passive
cannibalism and and the reason why I
mention this is that these terms are
actually used quite a lot also in
scientific papers so here you can see
just a few papers I've chosen to to
describe like you can read that majority
of death due to primarily you primarily
to cannibalism some of them I suspect
cannibalism toward their newborn pups or
dams tended to kill their pups
sometimes death loss is also referred to
as infanticide and I think that when you
write papers like this and you actually
actually describe the cause of death as
being due to cannibalism or due to
infant side then it's also saying that
the female has killed them but the
problem is that when you go through the
methods in these papers and you cannot
really see a clear description on how
this was observed so you can read that
females or law and cuffs were lost this
is that day or they were inspected daily
so of course you go in there once or
twice a day and you see that the pups
are being lost you can think that they
actually kill them but I think the
problem with us you mean something and
using these terms is that if you use
these terms enough and use then it kind
of becomes effect and then the fact is
not based on scientific evidence it's
just based on an assumption I think
that's when you have difficulties
actually being able to prevent the
problems because you are assuming
something that might not even be correct
so to try to find out if females do feel
there perhaps I observe a lot of video
recording so i had 10 to 10 female like
six mice and i knew they had loved her
livers so i took this video recordings i
looked at them to find the exact time
when the female give birth and from that
point i also knew that the Cubs had died
at a certain point so i just looked very
carefully at these recordings
birth and then until every single pub
dives so a lot of going back and forth
through these video recordings and just
to see what what happens between between
birth and death and I should actually
say that this is not something that was
very easy because mouse pups are very
small and females usually hide them in
the nest so that's why I often question
when people say that they have implants
idle females because I know that it's
very very difficult to see the actual
killing so anyways what I did find was
females ate the offspring but they were
already dead when they ate them so one
thing that I was a bit surprised of was
that penis actually interacted a lot
both with dead cops and lied offspring
so you can see that a female actually
retrieve a dead path back to the nest
you could see that she was lying and
like a nursing position with pups that
were not alive and you can also see that
she was manipulating and licking puff
said were not alive and and so how did I
know if they were not allowed and it was
actually the definition I had was that
the cop stopped moving and then I never
even saw a movement from that path again
so that's how I knew if they were
actually did at some point but at no
instance during these observations I
could see a female that had been acted
with the pups a path path that was
active and at no instance this resulted
in the path being still so every time
that a female let go of the path it'll
still moving and I also observed several
cases of the structure and that's
problems of giving birth so that's also
something else shall picture left later
and I also had several females who gave
birth two cups that never moved so they
were
still one I want to show some pictures I
know that these pictures are big lie
because they are from video recordings
but this is a typical example of a
female who gave birth to a litter she
had sort of a nest but it was kind of
scared and it wasn't a very nice nest
the pups were spread out I will try to
show you some of the tops little bit
very difficult to see so here's one pub
here's another one and a third pub here
is also one pub and then back here is
another pub and these pups were actually
alive and but the female didn't pay any
attention to them she was just lying
outside nest for hours and then the
movement became smaller and smaller and
then finally the park stopped moving so
these pups might have died and from
starvation or hypothermia this is
another female and who gave birth to
pops in the morning and then this is an
example of how she's lying in the nest
with the pups this path is actually dead
but she also had cops that were alive at
this point this is the same female and
to the left you can see that she has
left the nest the pups are spread out
and around the nest and it's not I mean
I call it a mess you can see these
females did not finish the material but
it's like the nest site so you can see
that this it's a bit and it's a small
cavity in the bedding too so on this
picture down to the left you can see
that or you can see that that some of
the cuts were still alive and sound
would bid on the pictured last picture
you can see a female lying than a
sleeping and at this point I think it
was only one path that was
still alive so you can see the time it's
been like the entire day and then the
next morning the next morning you can
see the female eating the phone so at
this point she had been in the cage with
dead pups for quite a while before
actually you know what do you see here
is a female who is in a kind of bad
shape and this is an example of dystopia
and did pop was stuck with his female
for about one hour gym for tuition and
this female was actually walking around
like this for in several times before
giving birth and she also left her nest
site before she gave birth so he
actually didn't give birth in her nest
and the path she gave birth to was never
seen you so these were dead but as you
can see this is not a female in a very
good shape this study has also been
published so if you want to read more
about this find information in this
paper so if we look on then if the pups
are not killed and how do they die well
just to give some short background on
maternal behavior mice it starts quite
early and during the station with
preparation of a nest then the female is
pregnant for about 18 to 21 days and she
gives birth to a large liver can be
eight to ten cups or six plus it depends
on the strain you use at the birth pups
are hairless and blind their depth they
are a full dependent on the mother for
builds nutrition and some regulatory
control so maternal behavior is very
important for survival all my senses and
since maternal behavior is so important
we actually wanted to know if there was
any difference between females who had
liquors that survived and letters that
died so we use the recordings from
previous experimental studies and we
have served extremes for 24 hours before
until 24 hours I'll figure 49 of the
Phoenix observed we deliver and 15 of
the females lots delicious so the video
recordings work from two experimental
studies and remise included were housed
in four different housing environments
so you can see here that they are housed
both without and in ft material at all
you can see they were housed with a
small amount of mr. material and then
also a bit more nesting material and the
returned items in the cage in total we
have served about 30 behaviors behaviors
were grouped into behavior categories
and they were mainly focused on
behaviors related to maternal behavior
and interaction between female and pups
we also wanted to look at some of normal
behaviors like climbing bars going bars
or moving half soul and so on and just
to keep in mind is that these results
were as I said based on and also to
houston in different house and
environments so what we found was that
females that successfully weaned their
litters they perform more nest-building
behavior during the day before profusion
and then we can also find an association
between being outside nest and having a
low little survival interestingly we
also found that fema that lost early
first they perform more parturition
related behaviors and this might
indicate that they had some problem
giving birth because some famous
actually have a very prolonged for
tuition so they can start and then they
can give birth law stuff off your cell
hours so this indicates that something
is not right so next building and being
outside the nest with a girl with the
two behaviors that were most strongly
associated with it or survival and so as
you can see here the higher proportion
of observations with nest building the
higher probability of survival and the
opposite in the higher proportion of
observations with teammate being outside
that the high probability of survival
since this building is a very important
behavior for mice and we also found that
it was influencing survival we wanted to
see more in detail how the amount of
nesting material influenced the ability
for the female to build nests so the
next step was to to look at this and we
used like six miles and a small amount
of nesting material or a large amount
and half a nested it's about one gram
and a larger amount the three necklace
is about 7 grams so it's not huge amount
but let's give you gives you a picture
and then we measured nest quality and we
use the naturalistic net score and also
added something called opacity less
coverage and I will go through this
little bit more in detail then we scored
an ass from mating every third day until
population after graduation we serve
every day until day 3 so this is just an
overview of the house singing
environments used in this study as you
can see we had a smaller amount for a
large amount we also had a nest
structure and that the idea would that
goes to see if it helped FEMA paper cups
inside earnest this picture illustrates
lots of different nests look like so to
the upper left you can speed a nest on
day 2 off the birth and and bill by
female who only had access to half a
master and then you can see the
differences and to the lower arrived you
can see and lifted on day one off the
corporation and a female had access to
the nesters and this structure as well
and I also want to say that then in this
study we actually didn't change the next
image here
so the Phoenix had the same nesting
material from the day of mating until
after birth so every time we clean the
heaviest we transferred the nest and of
course if it was solid we we would have
removed it but it was never dirty so we
just need the nest to the new cage this
is picture illustrating how the nest
look like and I will try to explain a
bit how we measured nest quality so when
we use the naturalistic next coordinates
it's basically you imagine like oh sorry
long shape so you basically imagine that
you have around like a a shape you look
at the shape of the nest and then you
also want to see how much walls are
built up around the inner cavity of the
mist and in the case as you can see here
quite a lot of very material has been
used as well in the nest and this is an
example of female but only had a small
amount of messing with you so the pups
were actually you don't really see the
pups here is a small that you can see
something pink in there so the perhaps
were actually brought down in the
bedding then hidden by the nesting jail
and what we saw was that sometimes the
shape was actually quite similar between
fina that had a large amount of mr.
material and females that only had a
small amount of esteem job but still it
was quite a big difference in the
appearance of illness so we wanted to
add something more so that's why we
added the and disability and opacity so
on the lower picture you can see how
this will score
this line is the disability so if the
female or the puffs are visible above
the nest age and a and b illustrates
that opacity so if you could see the
female or pops through the most wall so
in this case they would have a score of
3 on both opacity and disability because
as you can see as you can see here one
side of nest has a hole so the female is
not covered and at all from itself
okay so these are two pictures showing
the difference between latinas so as you
can see on the top picture this is a
very nicely shaped dome dome shaped nest
with only a small opening but as you can
see my also do business if they have a
small amount unless the material so the
mice have been using also the very
material you can see that bedding is
chewed into pieces and actually used to
to create the nest that is very it's
very obvious looking at these two
features that just giving the mice a
small amount or less material will never
enable them to build full of doom
shivnath so even if we could see in this
study that the animals actually did
build a nest and there was a significant
difference between treatment so the mice
that were given only a small amount of
nesting material they had lower opacity
on the lower coverage and they also only
had they also had a lower score on them
and an S scoring scale so it's
impossible for miles basically to build
nest with only small amount in the
future so might not be surprising that
more nesting trail will give mice and
ability to create loveliness of better
quality I wanted to include this picture
because this shows you how dead mice
pops mouth pops to look like and these
pictures are these pups are just a few
days old and they were found under the
bedding material so it could be kemah
card to find dead mouse pups actually
you have to go through the bedding
material
depending on how much you have but in
this study had quite a lot for bedding
material and they are they are as you
can see they don't have any wounds so if
the mother would have killed the cops
you would imagine to find some rooms on
the parts and to the lower right it's a
tough that's still inside an ellipse sec
and let's never alive this is another
picture this female was found in the
morning as you can see she's in quite a
bit bad shape you can see the sides are
really something in and you can see
parts of pops here and the interesting
thing is that female mice they normally
give birth during the night and and
partitions in mice are very rarely
monitored so if you come to the animal
facility in the morning you find a
female in a cage like this and this
means that this female could actually
have been suffering for quite a few
hours before someone and inspected the
cage
so i would like to start to conclude
this talk and what we do know is the
seeming lies often eat the dead
offspring so I know that it's very
common to find parking you cannot spring
or sometimes you don't find any cups at
all but it is it true that the females
kill them is it true there's more common
for from the Paris females to literally
curse is it is it actually giving you
better survival to leave the females
undisturbed well from what we found in
the studies we didn't find any support
for these assumptions I do want to
stress that when I'm talking about
leaving phemus understood and I'm
talking about not handling females or
moving cages we did not do any cage
cleaning or kids changing so that could
be a totally different thing if you
start to move the liver and female to a
new cage and I have not done any
observations on that but we could not
find lower survival in the females that
were handled all the mouse crops and we
did handle the mouse pups phone the day
they were born and we also separated
them from the female for a few after 10
minutes so we could not see that that
inspecting or hanging the females or the
cops would actually make the famous
philosopher
we did find that nest building is
associated with five party wagon and i
also want to stress that female
insufficient amount of mystery material
to express misleading behavior properly
and there are several studies on my
feeling in life and if you look into
these studies and your sirness building
in mice and just gathering the material
in the corner and sleeping on top of it
is actually not feeling the nice wants
to have a dome-shaped nest or most
points at me some mouse traps are still
worn and I think that problems to
infertility might be more common than we
are aware because we don't always see
this and sometimes you must have
problems they can they can be labor for
flowers and seem to have problems but
then we don't see it because we are not
in the animal facility and when we enter
the room in the morning we might have
noticed something was wrong or we find
we not another definition so I would
like to recommend always use a large
amount on the future and then when I say
large amount I mean an amount that
actually enables demise to fill the dome
sickness and also make sure that an
extra material is being used because
different strains might have different
needs and not all mice build nests in
exactly the same way so if the animal if
you see that you give enough material
but my son of losing it then i recommend
you to actually figure out why the
nesting pills or anything because mice
shouldn't already losses and and also
take time to investigate the vehicles
the party puffles do not justice team
might have died because if you as i have
stressed several times in this talk that
if you just assumed why the haps die it
will be very difficult to actually do
something too
like to prevent little us so this is
something I would really like to highly
recommend and if you were from this and
you write papers please use mortality or
liquor laws or something instead of
infanticide and candles if you are not
sure that the actually thing will
actually pleased with us and also
monitoring femurs a long time for
populations is something that I should I
think we should think more about because
these animals can actually be quite a
lot of pain and it could be a lot of
stuff thing for them to to have this
problem so I think we should actually
start to think more about how we monitor
mouse games when they did this i also
want to stress that if you use genetic
in my van nuys there are a lot of other
reasons that nice the pups might die and
the fertility is it's not optimal and
this talk i have been talking about
mainly black six mice and reading and
the normal like in conditions and there
are so much more things that are
complicating reading when you use
genetically modified mice so if you use
these lives and the head problems
excited to find out as much as we can
about the model you are you saying how
the mutation affects fertility do you
have lethal phenotype and how is the
ability of a female to take care of the
cops and so on so and as I said this is
this could be more complicated than this
and as I said before I have been working
a little bit so there is also a piece is
out there if you want to learn more read
more about the studies I have presented
today and please contact me if you can
handle popular pieces well thank you dr.
Webber for that really fascinating
presentation it's now time for the Q&A
session just a quick reminder if you
have a question that you'd like to ask
dr. Webber please do so now you can
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
just hack your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click
the send button will answer as many
questions that we have time for to get
started our first question for dr.
Webber is from Nancy who asks I think
you answered this a little bit but the
female on the study she wants to know
what breed they are and what the litter
lost is it the first litter that was
lost
sorry thank you for that question and so
if I got it right it was the sprain and
if it was the first occurs so um yes it
was mainly black six life that we used
but from the bleeding my third eye the
first thought I told about it was also
valve seals and when i calculated a
little off that i presented with twenty
to twenty percent for belsay and thirty
two percent for like six it was not only
first because it was the entire being
willful and that the opposite is the
behavior observations who have been
doing is females with first please great
thank you for that our second question
is from Damien who asked in your
experience does the presence or absence
at the male or a presence or absence of
the mail at time of parturition have any
effect on litter mortality so that's an
interesting question and these studies
that we have only absurd female mice so
we have removed me from the cage before
parturition and that's because we wanted
to observe the travel together the thing
is that may might actually do show a lot
of they do take care of the cops as well
so it depends a bit on the breeding
situation and how the whole how they are
kicked but some like some some may would
definitely help with taking care of the
cops so and a lot of breeding facilities
actually keep both female and mains
together continuously but I have not
done any studies to compare a survival
with or without the main but that's of
course interesting to slip into
okay next we have a question from Marcel
who asked can you rule out mackerel
environmental stress so I don't know
exactly if I know what means with micro
environmental stress so i would like to
specify that question a bit more that
would be helpful thank you okay um while
we wait for a clarification of work on
what macro environmental stress means
and we'll go on with another question
also from Marcel who asked we do not
have commercial nest materials what
common materials can we use
well it depends a lot on what kind of
study you're doing because different
materials that can have a difference can
be toxic or if it ends a loft on the
studies how it will affect months or
what you workin me and but there are I
mean the best materials other ones that
mimic the natural environment mode so i
would say in nest material that could
actually there are more structured like
paper strips or something that mice
could actually build something up and
but you I mean if you just you couldn't
just take like a paper like writing
paper because that could be a chart and
enjoy the pup so you have to be careful
to have something that's soft but they
structured so just try to find something
that might as well use and actually in
can't wait but there are so many
different nesting materials out there
and I think the ones like slide papers
or the ones where they can actually
create something or combination of
different materials so they can choose
but if I said it it depends a lot on
what kind of mice you have if it's it's
a breeding facility or because there are
a lot of things you have to take into
consideration with Daniel if you need
the material to this day I or non toxic
or whatever so yeah I hope that helped a
little bit ok next we have a comment
from is men who is from the University
Athens new suspension with the
presentation have you checked any
infectious agent present that may cause
the stillbirths and do you conduct
health monitoring
we have had something else in the room
why didn't these studies but we have not
specifically focused on why the pups are
stable I think that's also very
interesting question to the thing to
more because we were a bit surprised
that so many pups were actually still
one we would be didn't expect that so I
think that that would be really
interesting to see why why honest or
block or are they still born or is the
mother not then taking care of them like
not removing the any other sack of the
growth that's also something that could
be very interesting to look more into
definitely okay and we have another
question from Marcel to ask what is the
black material you have inside the cages
that keeps the nest in the corner and he
also wonders if the nest that are
building igloos or pipes help produce a
mortality rate so first of all we have
not done any studies observing my that
are provided with egos or pipes and we
had one study as you can see in one of
the studies the animals had both a
shelter of paper and one shelter of the
PVC the red material you can see here
this red you see nest but that would
actually not used at all so all females
in this cage system built their nests in
this other system yeah but I do not know
if the Eagles would reduce my healthy I
think that it's important for my skype
schellberg i think it's even more
important that we have there they're
given access to missing material so they
can actually build a nest and control
the temperature and the black
thing I guess that you I think we've
talked about the structure that if that
I presented this one this is a ceramic
material ceramic material that we just
used for this study equated if just to
see if it would help keeping the cups
inside the nest but at this point when
the pups are very young they are not
that noble at all so we would have to
look more into this if the pups are
older and if there were problems
wonderful older so but if the ceramic
coated we can we have clarification from
ourselves out the macro environmental
stress causing the mortality rate and by
macro and ventura macro environmental
stress he needs stress from outside a
cage the environment such as room
temperature noise and odor so do you
have any experience of that causing
mortality in the mice and we did not
specifically look at least this
different the things he mentioned and
but I think what's important to be aware
of is that it's always quick to rule out
please so if you have problems with Pat
mortality it could be a very good idea
to try to figure out what kind of noise
you have me on new room because there
are a lot of noise nano rooms I think
you're not here so make sure that and
see if if there's something we can do
and will it help but in my studies are
not addressed specifically so there are
as you mentioned a lot more that can be
done but also room temperature should be
aware of that the temperature in the
room and in the cage is not always the
same so that's also one reason is very
important to give you a nice nesting
material because then they can control
the temperature by actually building a
nest
providing a warm area for the for the
mouse post all those were our fantastic
questions and I would like once again
today Dr Weber for her presentation do
you have any final comments for the
audience well I would like to thank you
all for listening and thank you very
much for giving me a lot of interesting
questions and I also would like you to
just please contact me if you have more
questions or you have problems with
reading I would be happy to try to help
you out and so you can find that my
contact and also reference list in the
PDF that's the why the coolest officer
thank you very much for listening well
thank you once again dr. Webber before
we go I want to let it all know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing until August of 2016
you receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replaying please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's Levithan
that's all we have for now and thanks
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon okay